david is with us in houston texas hi
david how are you
you know i don't know whether to say
better than i deserve or focus but not
finished
i'm doing pretty well that's a pretty
good hogan impersonation there
david i'm gonna give you an a on that
one
hey thanks hey um i've got a question
for y'all
uh i'm 30 years old married i have
two kids three and under with one on the
way and
i am blessed to be debt-free except for
our mortgage
we got about 125k left to pay off on
that
kind of a backstory is you know i grew
up kind of as an fbu kid my parents did
it back in 2006.
i read your book dave total money
makeover in 2008 and we did fp as a
couple in 2013.
but i'm kind of struggling now um with
baby steps and burnout we're on baby
steps four five and six
uh we purchased our home in 2015 as a
double income no kids
and then in 2017 my wife quit after we
had our daughter in the middle of
hurricane harvey
and uh took a big pay cut there to about
70 k
then i was blessed i have a promotion
before i i got a 42
pay raise in 2019 so now i'm making
about 110k
um so my question i guess is you know
with all the things that i've found the
more money i make the more things that
they pay for whether that's
529 for the kids home insurance life
insurance
property tax et cetera so how can i keep
my eyes and our eyes on our financial
goal without running out of gas
during dates four five and six
well the first thing that comes to mind
is
baby steps one through three are gazelle
intensity
and four five and six are not you move
from intensity
intensity to intentionality
on for on four five and six so four five
and six
involves a budget for a vacation
it involves a budget for an upgraded
vehicle it involves a budget for
you're running a marathon here you're
not running a sprint
and so you're not on beans and rice rice
and beans and you make 110
000 you've done very well in your career
well done you're putting 15 percent of
your income away you don't have any
payments but a house payment you've got
an emergency fund in place
you have a very reasonable house
mortgage and you got some kids and
you're funding a 529
but you're you're slowing into a rhythm
run now you're not doing speed training
it's a marathon and i think you're still
have the trying to run the emotions at
least
if not maybe even trying to crank the
math down uh
as if you were still on gazelle
intensity that'll burn you up
you can't do that yeah and david you're
also at that stage of life
where you've got all of these young kids
you've got another one coming
so you're feeling the pressure and
destroying you're gonna get out
yeah along along with lack of sleep are
you working from home too
yes sir oh yeah man so you let's let's
be honest
the mindset on the financial side is
they've said it's a mindset it's the
intentionality factor
but what you're feeling is the stress
and strain from the other things of
life and i want to tell you as a former
master isolator
because i was perfect at it i thought
you don't want to do life alone
and so you want to get some good guys
around you you want to have a connection
and a relationship to talk about
the stresses and strains of the kids of
the pressure
uh it's one of those things where we're
not meant to do life alone so you need
some community
yeah and
you know it's the stage you're in oh yes
i mean
you've got uh there's not a lot of
traction mathematically
with where you are in these baby steps
and
the kids just keep piling up here and
you're
just like oh i'm stuck and he doesn't
get to leave
he's working from home yeah yeah there's
a lot that's a lot
you know you you're i think just saying
all that out loud
oh helps with the idea of burnout that
yes
a normal human being in your situation
would be stressed yes
so if you are stressed you are a normal
human you are normal you are not a
psychopath
no and if you were just clueless then i
would tell you i'd worry about your
mental health
you are feeling exactly where you are
right now in this season brother
we'll get you out of the house and
working yeah that'll be helpful it will
and we get the baby here the last one
that'll be that'll be gonna be the
that'll be helpful yeah and you get into
you know but you're not going to see
one of the frustrations that we've
watched people experience and i guess
we've all experienced that walk these
baby steps
is that you see such huge chunks of
traction
in the first three yeah and then when
you go to four five and six it just
slows down yes
and it's the long haul this is a it's a
five
seven year ten year slog that's just the
thought and we're just that's why we
budget in there for the upgrades and
some of the other things as you go along
you budget
right for this or that and um you know
if you need to back off on a 529 just a
little bit
in order to breathe have a fun
fund yes a little bit while you're here
this is the time that it's appropriate
to do that i just want you doing it on
purpose
and i don't want you to fall into debt
right because you take your
take your eyes completely off the ball
so you go from intensity to intention
null
yeah and that's where we want to be and
david just like the seasons of the
weather this season too will change
my friend it really will just hang in
there with your wife
make sure you guys relationship is
connected get some
coaching if you need to or some
counseling if you need to
but get some good guys around you so you
can do life with them because you got
other fellows that are feeling the same
thing
you know it's weird it feels like it's
yesterday in some ways and in some ways
it feels like it was a hundred years ago
but
the year rachel was born we filed
bankruptcy
we had no money that's why you file
bankruptcy and and i got a
toddler a marriage hanging on by a
thread i'm working from home
and i'm broke i got no money
and um you know sharon was to say the
least overwhelmed
she wanted me away she didn't want to
look at me to start with right then
that's pretty disgusted uh valid valid
but uh you know i mean we went through a
similar season
uh but much worse yeah in the sense of
there was not money for
uh the electric bill and there was not
money you know we're
i mean we didn't go hungry literally but
we were broke
we had no money and i had to go make
money every week in order to just pull
things together
and i got little babies my self-esteem
was destroyed
my marriage is on the rocks i mean it's
that was a tough tough season
and so it feels like when i talk about
it it comes up in my throat
and i remember it like it was yesterday
but it was you know
30 years ago so uh in that sense david
you're in a similar type thing but much
better
and i'm not saying yours is that your
feelings aren't valid they are valid
right uh but you're just that that's
what
that those young that young kid stage of
life they suck they suck the
marrow out of your bones yes emotionally
that's what they they're so needy
takers um we love them they're cute as
they can be but that's why
when i have all the grandbabies over i
mean that's how i send them back home
that's why i send them back home because
i love them but they need to go home and
have to go home
you know and it's just they you know
when you're when you're six months old
and you can't do anything for yourself
you're
all you are is a taker man i mean we
love you you're cute as a button
and uh papa dave's gonna bounce you on
my knee but uh
but they they do they pull the energy
out of
and the math out of everything and and
so it is valid to feel that
it's not really a burnout it's more of a
i'm not getting traction yeah fatigue
it's a fatigue
it is a fatigue yeah it's a mental it's
a math fatigue an emotional fatigue a
spiritual fatigue
a relational fatigue yep and uh so yeah
just own that
and and say that that's real get some
guys guys of young families around you
like chris suggested
form your group of guys get out of the
house yes
go to the store and just walk around go
in the backyard and hit a tree with a
stick
i don't know do something man i mean uh
that's get out of that house yeah let
your wife get out of the house too
take turns take turns yeah for god's
sakes yeah budget for a babysitter
that's a good thing
yeah i mean i'm with you brother that's
what we're saying but you'll get through
it and you can still hit your baby step
yes you can just don't let this cause
you to fall off the horse